The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Are we ready?
So good afternoon.
Just a reminder, this week we
see each other three times--
today on Wednesday and
Friday in this other lecture
hall for our mid-term exam.
Today we will finish
the big chapter
on light-atom interaction.
But we're not getting
rid of it, because we
will be transitioning
to an important aspect
of light-atom interaction.
And these are line shifts
and line broadening.
So today we start the next big
chapter-- line shifts and line
broadening.
But before I do that, we have to
finish light-atom interaction.
And I want to come back
to the rotating wave
approximation revisited.
So I'll revisit the revisit
of the rotating wave
approximation.
And sometimes when
I have discussions
with students after
class, I realize
that something which I
sort of casually mentioned
is either confusing or
interesting for you.
And there are two
aspects I actually
want to come back here.
So several people
reacted to that,
but some felt it was maybe a
little bit too complicated.
Or others asked me
about some details.
So let me come back
to two aspects.
And I hope you find
them interesting.
One is when we sorted
out all those terms,
those [? need two ?] angular
momentum selection rules.
But I made sort of the
innocent comment-- well,
if you have omega minus omega
in a time-dependent Hamiltonian,
one term is responsible
for absorption,
one is for emission.
And when more than one
person asked me about it,
I think many more than
one person in class
would like to know
more about it.
So therefore, let me spend the
first few minutes in explaining
why is a time-dependent
term in the Hamiltonian
with plus or minus
omega, why is one of them
responsible for
absorption, and one
is responsible for emission?
Well, we have
Schrodinger's equation,
which says that the change
of the amplitude in state one
has a term.
And if it started out with
population in state two--
let's say perturbation theory,
we start in state two--
then it is the only term where
the differential equation,
through an off-diagonal
matrix element
puts amplitude from
state two into state one.
So what I'm writing down here
is just Schrodinger's equation.
And the operator V
is the drive field
connecting state
two to state one.
And so if I just
integrate this equation
for a short time between
time t and t plus delta t,
and I'm asking, did we
change the population
of state one, which is
now our final state?
Well, then you integrate over
that for time interval delta t.
But now comes the point
that the initial state has,
in its time-dependent
wave function,
a vector which is e to
the minus i omega 2 t.
The final state,
which I called one,
has-- because it's a complex
conjugate-- plus omega 1 t.
And let's just
assume we have here
the proportionality
to e to the i omega t.
And let me just say omega can
now be positive and negative.
It will be part of
the answer whether it
should be positive or negative.
Well, this integral here becomes
an integral of e to the i,
omega 1 minus omega 2 plus
omega t integrated with time.
And this is an
oscillating function,
where if you integrated
with over time,
it will average to
zero unless omega
is equal or at least
close to the frequency
difference between
initial and excited state.
So actually, what
you encounter here
is-- well, what I've derived
for you here is actually,
you can say energy conservation.
I didn't assume it.
It is built into the time
evolution of the Schrodinger
equation, that you can
only go from state one
to state two or state two to one
if the drive term has a Fourier
component omega, which
makes up for the difference.
Or I'm using different
language now.
If, through the drive
term, you provide photons,
you provide quanta of
energy, where omega fulfills
the equation for
energy conservation.
And you also see from this
result, when omega 1 is higher
than omega 2, omega
has to be negative.
When the reverse is true,
omega has to be positive.
So that's why I said,
the e to the plus
i omega t term is
responsible for absorption.
The e to the minus
i omega t term
is responsible for
stimulated emission.
You also see, of
course-- but I stop here,
because I think you've
heard it often enough.
If you integrate over
short time delta t,
this equation has
to be fulfilled
only to within 1 over delta t.
This is sort of the
energy-time uncertainty.
For short times,
the photon energy
does not need to match
exactly the energy difference.
And you also realize
when we think
about omega is
close to resonance,
then e to the i omega
t does absorption.
But if you're in
the ground state,
e to the minus i
omega t, leads now
to a very rapid
oscillation here,
which is close to [? 2 ?]
omega oscillation.
And we've discussed that in the
context of the AC stark shift,
that this gives rise to
the [? proxy ?] shift.
We've also discussed that this
term is rapidly oscillating
and it's nothing else than the
counter-rotating term which
we usually neglect when
we do the rotating wave
approximation.
So everything we've
discussed in this context--
counter-rotating term, energy
conservation, Heisenberg's
uncertainty,
time-energy uncertainty
actually comes from
this kind of formalism.
Any question?
Of course, if you quantize
the electromagnetic field,
then you don't have a drive
term with e to the i omega t.
You just have a and a
[? degas ?] for the photons.
And the question, which
term absorbs a photon
or creates a photon,
does not exist.
Because you know it whether
it's a or a [? dega. ?] But
you have the two
choices, whether you
want to use a fully quantized
field with photon operators
or whether you want to use
the time-dependent formalism,
using a semi-classical
or classical field
in the Schrodinger equation.
The second comment
I wanted to do
is using the
semi-classical picture,
I was sort of going with you
through some examples when
the rotating wave approximation
is necessary, when not.
When do you have
counter-rotating terms.
And yes, everything I
told you is, I think,
is the best possible way
how you can-- I assume,
because I haven't found a better
one-- the best possible way
to present it and
explain it to using
the time-dependent
electromagnetic field.
But I realized
after class that it
may be useful to
quickly state what
I have said in using
the photon picture.
If we have circular
polarization,
we have, for given frequency,
annihilation and creation
operator.
But let's assume that the
mode we are considering
is right-handed
circularly polarized,
so the operator creates a
photon at frequency omega
with this right-handed
circular polarization.
So that means now if
we start from a level m
and we have now
light-atom interaction,
the operator which
annihilates a photon
with circular polarization
because of angular momentum
conservation can only
take us to a level
where the magnetic quantum
number is n plus 1.
Well, the operator A
[? dega ?] creates a photon
through stimulated emission.
And so this is now
our two-level system.
And now we should ask the
question, in terms of rotating
wave approximation,
is necessary or not,
are there
counter-rotating terms?
Well, the counter-rotating terms
are the non-intuitive terms,
where you start out
in the lowest state.
But now instead of absorbing
a photon, you emit a photon.
And the operator for
emission is this one.
So I can now ask, is
there another term?
Why don't we stick to the
blue color for the photons?
That there is a term which
is driven by the operator
A [? dega ?]
circularly polarized.
Well, the answer is,
there may be such a term,
but the state we need has
now a magnetic quantum
number of m minus 1 because
of angular momentum selection
rules.
So this here is the
counter-rotating term,
which you may or may not
neglect, depending whether you
want to make the rotating
wave approximation or not.
So therefore, if you got
a little bit confused
about the different
cases I considered
at the end of the
last lecture, then
you may just summarize the
many examples I gave you
in the lecture just
as a note which
you should keep in
the back of your head,
namely-- let me first
phrase it in words
and then write it down.
If you have circular
polarization and angular
momentum selection rules,
then the counter-rotating term
may require a third level and is
not part of two-level physics.
So if you have a situation where
the third level does not exist,
you do not have a
counter-rotating term.
However, in all situations
I've encountered in the lab,
this third level does exist.
OK.
So let me just write that
down-- counter-rotating term
for circularly
polarized radiation
requires a third level
which may not exist.
And then you don't
have this term.
But it does exist in most cases.
Anyway, just an additional
clarification for the topics
we had on Wednesday.
Any questions about that?
Yes.
STUDENT: Are there cases other
than a spin-1/2 system where it
doesn't exist?
PROFESSOR: Well, I mentioned
the example last class--
if you do spectroscopy
of an S2P transition
in the magnetic field
of a neutron star.
Then the same one
splitting is so huge
that, well, you can assume that
this has been shifted so far
away that it has been
completely suppressed.
Other than that, well, we
have the trivial situation
which we discussed in NMR.
If you simply have
spin one half,
then the total number
of levels is only two,
because we're talking about
spin up and spin down.
Or I constructed,
in the last class,
the forbidden transition, a
doublet S to doublet S state.
So that's two pairs
of S equals one half.
And then we are
missing this state
to couple any counter-rotating
term into the system.
OK.
The next subject is saturation.
Now, in this chapter,
I want to talk
about saturation in general.
I want to discuss monochromatic
light but also broadband light.
And I want to introduce
concepts of saturation intensity
of absorption cross section,
certain things which
I find extremely useful if I
want to understand what happens
when light interacts
with a system.
Just sort of to
whet your appetite,
I will sort of show you
that the absorption cross
section of a two-level
system is independent
whether you have a strong
or weak transition.
Some people think the
cross section should be--
but there is a
difference which is
important between monochromatic
and broadband light.
But in the end, the
concepts are very simple.
I should say, sometimes
I feel it's almost too
simple to present it in class.
On the other hand, if
I don't present it,
I can't make a few comments
and guide you through.
So my conclusion
now is, at least
for now, I show you
some prepared slides,
and I sort of step you through,
and make a few annotations,
and point out certain things.
We have already
partially transitioned
to teach you this material
through homework assignment.
This week's homework assignment,
which is due on Wednesday,
is almost completely
on saturation.
And I will make a few comments
where what I present you today
is an extension or different
from what you're learning
in the homework and vice versa.
Yes.
If I wanted to present
you saturation,
power broadening, and all
that in the purest form,
I would just preset you with
the Optical Bloch equations.
We can solve them.
And then we have everything
we want-- a result which
explains saturation
and a result which
explains power broadening.
And you do some of
it in your homework.
However, what I
want to show here
is that saturation is
actually a general feature
of a two-level system if you
have sort of three rates, which
I will explain to you in
a moment-- very similar
to Einstein's A
and B coefficient--
that all such systems
have saturation.
And then you may immediately
solve the Optical Bloch
creation for
monochromatic radiation.
But for broadband
radiation, we usually
don't use the Optical
Bloch equations,
because for infinitely
broad light,
there is no coherence
for which we
need Optical Bloch equations.
If you only have the
Optical Bloch equations,
you have solved for saturation
in one limiting case,
and you don't see that
the concept of saturation
is much broader.
So therefore, let us assume
that we have a two-level system.
And we have the
couple two levels
with a rate--
which you can think
of the rate of absorption, the
rate of stimulated emission.
And I call the rate
the unsaturated rate.
In addition, there
is some dissipation,
some spontaneous decay
described by gamma.
So Ru is the unsaturated
rate for absorption
and for stimulated emission.
Of course, you know even before
you solve those equations
that there must be some
saturation built in.
If you would look at
the fraction of atoms
in the excited state and
you change the laser power,
which means changing
the unsaturated rate,
things cannot shoot up forever,
because you cannot put more
than 100% of the population
into the excited state.
However, the effect that when
we increase the laser power,
we do upwards absorption
and downward stimulation--
means you won't even get 100%.
The maximum you can get is 50%.
And what I'm just
drawing for you is
this is a phenomenon
of saturation,
and now we want to
understand the details.
So using this rate
equation, we are
defining-- this is now a
definition-- the saturated rate
is the net transfer from A to B.
Because we have an absorption
and stimulated emission,
the net transfer is the
[? unsaturated ?] rate
times the population difference.
And this is our saturated rate.
But of course, we normalize
everything for atom.
So therefore, our saturated
rate has a rate coefficient S
times the total number of
atoms, or the total population
in both states.
Eventually, we are
interested in steady state.
We can immediately
solve the rate equation
in terms of steady state,
which is done there.
And we find that for
those, we can now
eliminate one of the
states from the equation,
because we have the
steady state ratio.
And then we find that
the saturated rate
is gamma over 2 times
an expression which
involves a saturation parameter.
So in other words, it's just
almost trivial solutions
of very simple equations,
which describe the saturation
phenomenon I outlined
for you at the beginning.
This solution has the
two limiting cases
which we want to see-- that at
a very low unsaturated rate,
the saturated rate is the
unsaturated rate because there
is no saturation.
And secondly, if we would
go to infinite power,
the saturated rate
becomes gamma over 2,
because we have equalized
the population between ground
and excited state.
One half of the atoms
are in the excited state,
and they dissipate or scatter
light with the rate gamma.
All right.
Any questions?
We now want to specialize it
to a situation which we often
encounter, namely
monochromatic radiation.
And for monochromatic
radiation, the unsaturated rate
follows-- well, I factored
out something here.
But it follows the
normalized line shape,
which is a Lorentzian.
And therefore, our
unsaturated rate
is proportion to
the laser power.
But I usually like to express
the laser power through a Rabi
frequency or the Rabi
frequency squared.
So our unsaturated rate
follows this Lorentzian.
And on resonance,
this part is one.
Our rate is omega Rabi
squared over comma.
And the definition for the
saturation parameter of one,
or for the saturation intensity
is that the unsaturated rate
has to be gamma over 2.
So therefore, by
omega Rabi squared
over gamma is the
unsaturated rate,
it should be gamma
over 2 for saturation,
for saturation parameter of one.
So therefore, our saturation
pentameter resonance
is given by this expression.
And if you use the
previous result
and apply it to this
unsaturated rate,
we find a saturated
rate which shows now
the new phenomenon
of power broadening.
Let me illustrate
it in two ways.
The saturated rate involves
a saturation parameter,
and the unsaturated
rate is a Lorentzian.
But this Lorentzian appears
now in the numerator
and the denominator.
So it appears twice.
But with a one-step
manipulation,
you can transform it
into a single Lorentzian.
But this single Lorentzian
is now power-broadened.
It no longer has
[? width ?] of gamma
over-- of the natural
line with gamma.
It has an additional term,
and this is power broadening.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
It's still-- the resonance
is at [? 0 ?] [INAUDIBLE].
The equations are trivial.
It's really just
substituting one
and getting from an
expression, simplifying it
to simple Lorentzian.
I just want to
emphasize the result.
If you drive a
transition, we have
now-- the [? width ?] of the
Lorentzian is now gamma over 2
if we have no saturation.
But then if we crank up
the saturation parameter,
the [? width ?] increases with
a square root of the power.
That's an important result.
The square root of the
power leads to broadening.
Now let me give you a
pictorial description
of what we have done here.
If we start with the Lorentzian
and we increase the power,
you sort of want to drive
the system with the stronger
Lorentzian.
But we know we have a
ceiling, which is saturation.
And of course, when
you drive it stronger,
you reach the
ceiling on resonance
earlier than you reach the
ceiling when you transfer it
away from resonance.
So therefore, if you
start with the red curve,
crank up the power,
you will get more
of a factor, more of
a result in the wings
because you are not
yet saturated there.
And this graphical construction,
which I have just sort of
indicated to you, lead now to
a curve which is broadened,
broader than the
original Lorentzian.
And this is the reason
behind power broadening.
I want to mention
one thing here.
For the classroom
discussion, I have
assumed that the light-atom
interaction can be described
by Fermi's golden rule, which
we know is a limitation.
When the system is,
in effect, incoherent
or no longer coherent,
we had a long discussion
about Rabi oscillation,
Fermi's golden rule
in the last two weeks.
But what I'm doing is
mathematically correct.
The Optical Bloch
equation, which
you'll use in your
homework assignment,
will include the transition
from Rabi oscillation
towards Fermi's golden rule.
And I'm just considering
this [? fundamental ?] case.
OK.
I've talked about
saturation of a transition.
I've mentioned that we
have defined the saturation
parameter such that when we have
saturation parameter of one,
we sort of get into
the non-linear regime
where saturation happens.
And of course, for
an experimentalist,
the next question is, at what
intensity does that happen?
This is summarized
in those equations.
It's as simple as
possible algebra.
You just combine two equations.
I don't want to do it here.
And we have a result for the
saturation intensity, which
has two features, which
I want to point out.
One is [? its case ?]
with omega cube.
So the higher the frequency
of your transition is,
the harder it is to saturate.
Of course, it has something
to do with that in saturation,
you have an
unsaturated rate, which
is one half of the
spontaneous emission rate.
And you remember that the
spontaneous emission rate
was proportional to omega cube.
So that's why we have,
again, the omega cube factor.
And in addition, the larger--
actually, it depends.
Sorry.
I made a mistake.
Well, you can write the
results in several ways.
If you have an intensity
and you go back to photons,
you get factors of omega.
So when I said omega cubed comes
from the natural line widths,
yes, it does, but it's
not the only omega factor.
You can write the
result actually
that you have a gamma
squared dependence,
because one gamma comes from
the matrix element squared
and one comes because you need
to compete in your excitation
with spontaneous emission.
So anyway, this is
sort of the result.
And you can calculate it
for your favorite atom.
And for alkaline
atoms, we usually find
that the saturation
intensity is a few milliwatt
per square centimeter
Well, we can now repeat
some of this exercise
for the broadband case.
In the broadband case,
the unsaturated rate,
which is the rate for absorption
in stimulated emission,
following Einstein's treatment
of the AB coefficient
is used by using
Einstein's B coefficient
times the spectral intensity.
And now we want the same
situation as before.
We want to reach saturation.
And saturation happens when
this is comparable with gamma.
And it's purely a
definition that we
say it should be gamma over 2.
But we are consistent
with what we did before.
And if you just
take this equation
and calculate what the
saturation intensity is,
well, gamma is nothing else
than the Einstein A coefficient.
Here we have the
Einstein B coefficient.
And if we take the ratio
between the Einstein A and B
coefficient, the matrix
element, everything
which is specific to
the atom, cancels out.
And the saturation intensity,
or the spectral density--
it's the spectral density
now for broadband--
only depends on speed of light
and the transition frequency
cube.
And it doesn't make a
difference whether you
have a two-level system which
has a strong matrix element
or weak matrix element.
I could explain it to
you now at this point,
but we want to hold
the idea that there
is a difference
between single mode
monochromatic and
broadband excitation
until I have discussed
one more concept.
And this is the cross section.
Just to check, are
there any questions?
Yes, Nancy.
AUDIENCE: So in
the broadband case,
the line shift
doesn't matter at all?
Because in the
monochromatic case,
we had a line shift [INAUDIBLE].
Well, hold your question.
The line shape matters.
I will now discuss what is
the line shape of the atom.
And the quick answer is, if
the atom has a line shape,
we have to take the
atomic line shape
and do a convolution with
the line of the radiation.
And we have the two
situations where in one case,
the monochromatic
light is narrower
than the line
shape of the atoms.
In the other case, it's broader.
And this difference,
in the end, will
be responsible for the
effect that the line widths
of the atom, which is
the natural line widths,
will cancel out in one
case and not in the other.
But that's actually the result
of the next five minutes.
Other questions?
I know this topic
can get confusing,
because we go from one
definition to the next.
So let me just summarize.
What I've said so far is
we [? derive ?] an atom.
We have absorption, we
have stimulated emission.
And we want to understand
the phenomenon of saturation.
And based on the effect how
we define saturation, namely
that the unsaturated
rate is gamma over 2,
we got some nice results
for the saturation intensity
and for power broadening
of a Lorentzian.
So it's pretty much having a
definition and running with it.
And now we want to
express the same physics
by using the concept
of a cross section
for the following reason.
You can do physics, you
can do atomic physics
without ever thinking
about a cross section.
You can just say, I have a laser
beam of a certain intensity,
and I scatter light.
But often, when we
scatter something--
and you may be familiar,
from atomic collisions--
you often want to write
the scattering rate
as a density times cross
section times relative velocity.
And this sort of has
this intuitive feeling.
If you have a stream of
particles in your accelerator
or a stream of photons
in your laser beam,
you can now hold
onto the picture
that each atom in your
target is a little disk.
If the particle of photons hits
the disk, something happens.
If it misses the
disk, nothing happens.
And the area of the disk
is this cross section.
So in other words, we
want to now understand
how big is the disk of the
atom which will, so to speak,
cast the shadow, which is
synonymous with absorption,
when we illuminate those
atoms with laser light.
So for me, a very
intuitive quantity.
Anyway, so all we do
is we have already
discussed the rate
of excitation,
which is now the
unsaturated rate.
But now we express
the unsaturated rate
by the density of photons
times the cross section.
And the relative velocity
is the speed of light.
And from this equation, we
find-- because everything
is known, we have talked about
that on the last few pages--
we find that the cross section
is-- and this is the result.
6 pi lambda bar square.
Lambda bar is the wavelengths
of light divided by 2 pi.
So we find that for
monochromatic radiation,
the cross sectional
of a two-level system
is independent of the
strength of the transition,
independent of the
matrix element.
It just depends on the
resonant wavelengths.
Now you would say,
well, but what is now
the difference between a
strong and a weak transition?
And this is shown here.
If you take your monochromatic
laser and you scan it,
you scan it through
the cross section.
When you are on resonance, you
have 6 pi lambda bar square.
And the difference between
a narrow transition
with a small Einstein
A coefficient
and a strong transition with
a large Einstein A coefficient
simply means that in
one case, it's narrower.
In the other case, it's wider.
We talked about the
phenomenon of saturation.
6 pi lambda bar squared
is the cross section
in the perturbative limit, or
the unsaturated cross section.
Of course, if you
increase the laser power,
you saturation the transition.
The atom will have a smaller
and smaller cross section.
Actually, that's something
important you should consider.
When you have an atom and
you increase the laser power,
you scatter light.
And the scattered light, or
the absorbed light, saturates.
But with the cross
section, we want
to know what fraction of the
laser light is scattered.
And the fraction of the
laser light scattered
goes to zero, because
you make your laser
light stronger and stronger.
And the total amount of laser
light which is scattered
saturates.
So in other words,
you have a saturation
of the scattered light.
You have a saturation of
the net transfer of atoms
through the excited state in the
limit of infinite laser power.
But since the cross section is
sort of normalized by the laser
power, the cross section has
this dependence, 1 over 1
plus saturation
parameter, and goes to 0.
And that means--
and this is sort
of the language we use-- that
the transition bleaches out.
If you saturation
the transition,
the cross section
becomes smaller.
So when you saturation the
transition in an absorption
imaging experiment,
which many of you do,
the shadow is less
and less black
exactly because the cross
section is bleaching out.
But the amount of
light you would scatter
you would observe
in fluorescence
is not getting
less, it saturates.
This is sort of just the
two flip sides of the coin.
If anybody is confused,
please ask a question.
OK.
So now in this picture,
we can immediately
understand why we
have differences
between monochromatic radiation
and broadband radiation.
If you want to
saturation a transition
with monochromatic radiation,
we have our narrow laser.
We absorb with a cross section
6 pi lambda bar square.
And we have to increase
the intensity of the laser
until the excitation
rate equals gamma over 2.
That's our definition
for saturation.
So therefore, the
laser intensity
is proportional to
gamma, because we
have the cross
section is constant,
but the product of cross
section and laser intensity
has to be equal to gamma over 2.
However, now consider
the case that you
use broadband radiation.
The spectrum is
completely broad.
Now, if an atom has a
stronger transition,
its cross section is
wider, and the atom
can sort of absorb a wider
part of the incident spectrum.
So therefore, if the atom
has a stronger transition,
it automatically takes, absorbs
more of your spectral profile.
And therefore, the
result for the saturation
and for the spectral
saturation intensity
is independent of
the matrix element
and the strengths
of the transition.
In general, if
you're not in either
of the extreme cases
of monochromatic light
or broadband light,
what you have to do
is you have to use
this cross section
as a function of
frequency, and convolve it
to a convolution with a
spectrum of the incident light.
And this is exactly done here.
You take your
frequency-dependent cross
section.
You do the convolution with the
spectrum of the incident light.
And if you assume the incident
light is spectrally very broad,
you simply integrate over
the Lorentzian line shape
of the cross section.
And then you find
exactly the same result
as we had two slides ago,
that the saturation intensity
is independent of the
strengths of the transition.
OK.
Can you think of a
very intuitive argument
why for spectrally
broad radiation,
all the properties of
the atoms cancel out?
If you think about one physical
example for, let's say,
black body radiation--
this is spectrally broad.
So you have an atom in
a black body cavity.
And the atom experiences
a very broad spectrum.
For what number of photons,
black body photons per mode
would we find saturation?
Think about it.
It's a simple criterion you
can formulate for black body
radiation to saturation
your transition in terms
of the number of
photons per mode.
You crank up the
temperature in your cavity.
How high do you have to
go with the temperature
in order to saturate an atom
which is inside your black body
cavity?
AUDIENCE: One photon.
PROFESSOR: Pretty close.
AUDIENCE: 1 over
[? degenerates. ?]
PROFESSOR:
[? Degenerates. ?] OK.
No [? degenerates. ?] I
hate [? degenerates. ?]
That's your private homework
to put in [? degenerates ?]
afterwards.
The answer I came was
n equals 1/2, I think.
I run the risk that I'm
off by a factor of 2 now.
But the argument was that--
AUDIENCE: The rate equals
[? degeneracy ?] by n by gamma.
So if the rate equals
gamma over 1/2,
that mean that [? degenerates ?]
by n equals 1/2.
And if [? degenerates ?]
equals 1, n equals 1/2.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
So spontaneous emission, we
know that spontaneous emission--
from our derivation of
spontaneous emission--
corresponds to one
photon per mode.
And our criterion now is that we
want to have an absorption rate
or stimulated rate
which is gamma over 2.
So we get sort of 1/2 the effect
of spontaneous emission when
we have 1/2 a photon per mode.
So therefore, spontaneous
emission absorption
is proportional to n.
And I think if n
equals 1/2, then
we have the unsaturated
rates equal to gamma over 2.
So this is a very
physical argument.
When we put an atom into
a black body cavity,
and we have 1/2 a photon
per mode occupation number,
then we saturate
any atom we put in.
Because using Einstein's
argument, we have now the rate
coefficient for
absorption emission
for stimulated emission
and absorption is just 1/2
of the rate coefficient
for spontaneous emission.
And that explains that
all atomic properties
have to cancel out.
So now question for you.
We talked about the fact that if
you have hyperfine transitions,
that it would take--
what was the value?
1,000 years for
spontaneous emission?
So that we can completely
neglect spontaneous emission.
On the other hand, we've just
learned that saturation only
comes from spontaneous emission.
Without spontaneous emission,
we wouldn't have saturation.
But now I'm telling you
that any atom should really
be saturated if we put
it in a black body cavity
where n bar is 1/2.
So what is the story now if we
put an atom into a black body
cavity, and we are asking
about, will we saturate?
The hyperfine transition.
Will we eventually
have-- saturation
means we have [BLOWS AIR], 1/4
of the atoms in the excited
state, 3/4 in the ground state.
So the delta n has been reduced
from 1, which it was initially,
to 3/4 minus 1/4, which is 1/2.
What will happen?
I mean, this was almost like
a thermodynamic argument.
Will we equilibrate and
saturate hyperfine transitions
in a black body cavity
based on this argument
that for n bar equals
1/2, we should really
saturate everything?
AUDIENCE: Yes, but it's
going to take a long time?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So for those conditions,
if your black body cavity
was n bar equals 1/2, you should
saturate any two-level system
completely independent
what gamma is.
And if the gamma is 10
nanoseconds or 10,000 years,
you will saturate it.
The value of gamma
has completely
dropped out of the argument.
But of course, if you want to
reach any kind of equilibrium,
it will take a time scale,
which is 1 over gamma.
And then we are
back to 1,000 years.
Questions?
All right.
Then let's conclude this
chapter and start our discussion
about line shifts
and line broadening.
I have a problem with
the tablet computer.
I draw a line, but the computer
draws a line somewhere else.
So maybe I should just go
back to this one and then copy
things over.
OK.
Our next big chapter is
line shifts and broadening.
So the first question
is motivational.
Why should we be interested
in line broadening?
Well, the answer
is almost trivial.
No resonance is
infinitely narrow.
Whenever we want to interpret
any result we obtain
spectroscopically, we are not
observing a delta function,
we are not observing
a resonance,
we are observing a line shape.
And unless we understand
the line shape,
we may not accurately find
the resonance frequency.
You could, of course, assume
that your line shape is
symmetric, which may be the
case but is not always the case.
So without understanding
line broadening,
you cannot interpret
spectroscopic information.
And eventually, as I
mentioned in the first chapter
of this course, the art
of analyzing line shapes
and finding the line center
is very well advanced.
When we have caesium
fountain clocks,
the accuracy how you operate the
clock as a frequency standard
is on the order
of one microhertz.
But those fountain
clocks with you toss up
the atoms for one second
in the atomic fountain,
they fall up and down,
well, like a rock,
which takes about a second for a
rock to go up and down a meter.
So therefore, the line width
is on the order of one Hertz.
So therefore, people have to
understand any single aspect
of the line shape at the
level of 10 to the minus 5,
or 10 to the minus 6 to
have this kind of accuracy.
OK.
So I thought I want to start
this unit by collecting form
you examples for phenomena which
cause broadening and shifting
of lines.
And well, my list
has about 10 of them.
Let's see how many you get.
So what phenomena can lead
to line shifts and line
broadening?
AUDIENCE: Phonons.
PROFESSOR: Phonons?
In terms of-- OK,
AC stark effect.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Magnetic field noise.
PROFESSOR: Magnetic field noise.
OK.
I tried to-- yes, very good.
OK, yes.
Let me just try to
group it a little bit
further, because I
want to discuss it.
So we have external fields.
And external fields can
have AC stark shifts.
If an external field is noisy,
we have noise fluctuations.
All right.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Doppler shift.
PROFESSOR: Doppler shift.
Yes.
So we have the
velocity of the atoms.
Doppler shift.
AUDIENCE: Collisions.
PROFESSOR: Collisions.
Very good.
Well, we just talked
about one thing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
When we have external
fields, we can
have external fields
like magnetic fields
or electric fields which
cause shift and broadening.
And if there's noise,
additional shifts.
But when we regard those
fields as drive fields,
they can do power broadening.
Maybe by collisions, I should
add the keyboard "pressure
broadening."
The higher the pressure
in your gas cell is,
the more collisions you have and
the more you have broadening.
Other suggestion?
If you don't have
any of those effects,
do you measure delta function?
What's the line width?
Will?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: Spontaneous emission.
PROFESSOR: Spontaneous emission.
Yes.
And if you don't have
spontaneous emission,
do we then measure
delta function?
STUDENT: There's
a Fourier limit.
PROFESSOR: The Fourier limit.
You can call it
observation time,
or time of light broadening.
If an atom flies
through your laser beam
and you can interrogate
it only for a finite time,
you have a broadening due
to the Fourier theorem.
And this can be called time of
flight broadening and time of--
or interaction time broadening.
STUDENT: Rotations
and vibrations?
PROFESSOR: Rotations
and vibrations.
Not really.
These are more-- then the
system has more energy levels,
and that's what you
want to find out.
So maybe I'm more asking,
how are those energy levels--
how do they appear
spectroscopically?
Well, I think that's
pretty complete.
Two external fields.
If you want, you
can add gravity.
There is a
gravitational red shift,
which is general relativity.
But anyway, let me look over
that and try to categorize it.
What we had here actually all
comes from a finite observation
time.
Either we do not have the atom
long enough in our laser beam,
and that sets a limit.
Or if you are interested in an
excited state and the excited
state decays, then
the atoms themselves
have terminated our
interrogation time.
The second class
here, velocity, I
would summarize that we
have motion of the atom.
It's a form of
motional broadening.
We will actually discuss,
when we discuss motion, also
the possibility of having
atoms in a harmonic oscillator
potential, ions in an ion trap.
So these are now
trapped particles.
This will actually often give
rise to a splitting of the line
into side bends.
So we want to discuss that.
I've already mentioned external
fields, conditional [INAUDIBLE]
interrogation, power broadening.
Some power broadening
will actually
result into a splitting of
line into [INAUDIBLE] triplet.
So power will not
only broaden the line,
it can also split the line.
And we want to discuss that.
And finally, we have the
effect of atomic interactions.
So for interactions, I think
we should add something
like mean field shifts,
which also goes sometimes
by the name of clock shift.
If you're not at zero
density, your transition
can be shifted by the
presence of other atoms.
Will?
STUDENT: Isn't collisional
broadening or pressure
broadening sort of
just an ensemble
average of a stark effect?
So that's sort of
an external field?
PROFESSOR: That depends now.
Collisions is one of the richest
phenomena on the list here.
You're ahead of me.
But in the next few minutes,
I wanted to actually
see, well, maybe we should--
those categories are not
mutually exclusive, because
one part of collisions is.
An atom is in the excited
state, it collides,
it gets de-excited.
So then collisions
have no other effect
than sort of give us a
finite observation time,
where there is an effective
lifetime, which is just
the time between two collisions.
So it can be this.
There's another
aspect of collisions,
that every time
there is a collision,
an atom feels the electric
field of another atom.
And then we have some form
of collisional broadening,
because we do some statistical
averaging over stark effects,
over level shifts.
Now, there is a third
aspect of collisions,
which is maybe surprising
to many of you.
And this is actually-- I
put it here under motion.
It is collisional narrowing,
or [? diche ?] narrowing.
There's one limiting case
when you have collisions,
that collisions lead to a
narrower line and not only
to a broader line.
the reason is a little bit-- if
you put an atom in a buffer gas
and it collides with
all the buffer gas atom,
it cannot fly away.
So buffer gas and
collisions can sort of
help to increase your
observation time.
But only if the other effects
of collisions are absent.
So anyway, I thought
this is a number
of really interesting effects.
And you already see from my
presentation and discussion
that it makes perfect sense to
discuss them not one by one,
as they appear in
other chapters,
but try to have comprehensive
discussions of those.
Let me talk about one
classification of those shifts
and broadening.
And one is the distinction
between homogeneous
and inhomogeneous broadening.
So the picture
here is that if you
have-- let me just give
you the cartoon picture.
If you have different atoms,
atom 1, atom 2, atom 3.
A homogeneous
broadening situation
is if the line
has been broadened
for each atom in the same way.
An inhomogeneous
broadening situation
is that atom 1 has a line
here, atom 2 has a line here,
atom 3 has a line there.
And if you look at the
statistical ensemble,
you may find the
same line widths
as on the left-hand side, but
the situation and the mechanism
is a very different one.
So the different characteristics
are that here, we
have a mechanism which
broadens or widens
the line for each atom.
Whereas here, there is
maybe not even any line
broadening for the atom.
It's more a random shift
to individual atoms.
And the widening happens
for the ensemble.
Another very
important distinction
is in the left case, if you
have one powerful laser,
it can talk to all the atoms.
Whereas in the
right-hand side, you
may have a laser with
a certain frequency,
and it may only excite one
group of atoms in your ensemble.
So this is the opposite here.
In many situations do we have
a physical picture where,
in homogeneous broadening,
we can understand it
as random interruptions of the
phase's evolution of the atom.
For instance, through
spontaneous emission,
or you can see certain
collisions-- just mean
the phase of the excited
state is suddenly perturbed.
And therefore, the
phase is randomized.
So if the physical picture
is a random interruption
of the phase evolution,
well, a random interruption
of a phase evolution
means that there
is an exponential
decay of coherence.
And the line shape,
the Fourier transform
of an exponential
decay is a Lorentzian.
Whereas the physical picture
behind inhomogeneous broadening
is that you have
random perturbations.
And if you have many random
or small perturbations,
they often follow a
normal distribution,
which is a Gaussian.
There's one other aspect of
an inhomogeneous broadening.
If it's an inhomogeneous
broadening,
it is as if the individual
atom is not broadened,
the individual atom
is actually sharp,
it has a longer coherence.
And you can-- there
are techniques to make
that visible.
And one famous technique,
for those of you
who have heard about it,
are an echo technique.
So having explained to
you in a general way
the difference between
inhomogeneous and homogeneous
broadening, how would you
classify the line broadening
mechanisms we have
collected before?
Which one are
inhomogeneous broadening?
STUDENT: Doppler broadening.
PROFESSOR: Doppler broadening.
We exploit that when we
do saturation spectroscopy
in the lab, when we just talk
to one component of the velocity
distribution.
What else?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: Collisions.
PROFESSOR: Collisions.
That's actually a good one.
Usually, collisions
are classified
as homogeneous broadening,
because the simplest
model for collisions
is collisions
are sort of just hard-core
collisions which just de-excite
the atom, completely change
the coherent phase evolution.
And therefore, collisions
would broaden the transition
for all atoms to a
line widths which
is 1 over the collision rates.
However-- and this shows that
the distinction cannot always
be made-- you can actually have
collision rate which depends
on the velocity.
The faster atoms may have
a smaller collision cross
section than the slower atoms.
And now you have an
inhomogeneous aspect
of the collision rate.
And therefore, collision
rate becomes inhomogeneous.
I mean, the standard example
for inhomogeneous fields
would-- if you have an
inhomogeneous magnetic field,
you have stationary atoms--
well, not in an atomic gas,
but maybe in [INAUDIBLE]
or in a solid.
And you have an
inhomogeneous magnetic field.
This is actually
the standard case
of nuclear magnetic
resonance, that each atom
possesses at its
local magnetic field.
And the line shape is
inhomogeneously broadened.
Colin?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
clock shift sometimes,
in some circumstances.
PROFESSOR: If the
density is constant,
you would actually
say the mean field is
the same for all
atoms in the ensemble.
But if you have a
trapped atom sample
where the density
drops at the edge,
you may actually
have a sharper line,
and less broadening, or less
shift at the edge of the cloud.
Anyway, so I think you have
all the tools to classify it.
And you see from the
discussion that sometimes it's
not so obvious.
Or you may have
a mechanism which
has [? both ?] inhomogeneous
that it does something
to all atoms.
So for instance, collisions
broaden all the atoms,
but then different atoms are
more broadened than others.
So there may be also an
inhomogeneous aspect.
But finally, let me
ask you the following.
It seems the first
items on our list
had sort of a very
natural explanation
in terms of the Fourier theorem,
that, well, we only talk
to the atoms for a finite time.
Or the atoms decide not
to talk to us for longer,
because they
spontaneously decay.
Now, maybe you want to
give me some arguments why
some of the other
mechanisms are actually
also due to some form of
finite time of interrogation.
Well, if I would say,
can we regard collisions
as an effect of finite
observation time?
Well, if I rephrase "observation
time" to "finite coherence
time," that something interrupts
the coherent evolution
of the wave function,
I think we would
say the collision time sets
a time limit to the coherence
time and therefore,
should also be regarded
as due to the
finite time, we can
drive the atom in
a coherent fashion.
If I take power
broadening, we just
discussed power broadening.
Well, what is the rate--
or 1 over the rate
of power broadening?
We just discussed
that that's maybe
nice to take it
out of the context.
We discussed before that
power-broadened line widths
is gamma over 2 times S
plus 1 square root of it--
the saturation parameter.
But when does power
broadening happening?
And what is the real time scale
for what is the physical--
STUDENT: Spontaneous emission.
PROFESSOR: Spontaneous--
so we had a criterion
that the unsaturated rate has
to be comparable to gamma.
Let's forget about
factors of 2 now.
But that means that
the Rabi frequency
has to be comparable to gamma.
The Rabi frequency tells
us a time of Rabi flopping.
So actually, power
broadening can
be understood as a finite
observation time broadening,
but the atom is leaving
the excited state
not by spontaneous emission,
but by stimulated emission.
So in other words,
stimulated emission
interrupts our ability
to observe the atoms
in the excited state.
And so again, we see that
there is a process coming
in which interrupts
our observation
time of the unperturbed
atomic levels.
Well, let me go
one step further.
Let me ask you, do
you have any idea
how we could discuss
the Doppler shift as
due to some finite time scale?
You would say, well, yeah,
that's dimensional analysis.
If you have a broadening, a
broadening is a frequency,
1 over the frequency
is the time,
and there is a time
scale associated
with Doppler broadening.
Sure.
But now my question is,
what is the physical time
scale with Doppler broadening?
Yes?
STUDENT: [? Collisions. ?]
PROFESSOR: No.
We have an ideal gas without
any collisions-- just
a [INAUDIBLE] distribution.
You're right.
In practice, yes.
But I try to create an
idealized situation.
So what is the time scale
of Doppler broadening?
You may have never
heard the question.
But this is for me, what
I want to really teach you
when I teach all these
different line shifts
and line broadening.
There is a common denominator.
STUDENT: You could think of
the atom [INAUDIBLE] emission.
And then you would have
velocity [INAUDIBLE] emission.
PROFESSOR: You're talking
about recoil shifts,
and the atom is changing
its velocity due to recoil.
This would something
in addition,
but it's not necessarily
the case here.
I give you a physical argument.
If I make the atom heavier
and heavier and heavier,
the effect of the recoil vanish.
But then I can heat
up the heavier atom,
that it moves with the same
velocity as the slow atom.
So there is an effect which
you can associate just
to the velocity and to
the velocity distribution.
And that's what I
want to discuss now.
But there is another
effect with the recoil.
But I can say the
recoil is a finite mass
effect, for that purpose.
The mass is sort of my
handle, whether the recoil
of a singular photon
is important or not.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
but this is really
a more trivial finite
observation time.
When you heat the
wall of the chamber,
it's a collision
with the chamber.
It means we have only a
finite interaction size.
Now, let me sort of
guide you to that.
The secret here is
when we say, you
have a finite lifetime, a
finite observation time,
what matters when
we do spectroscopy
is the time we can observe
the atoms coherently.
If the atoms de-phase,
if the atoms get out
of coherence-- for instance,
if you have collisions--
if collision de-excite
the atom-- we'll
talk about it later-- it's
like spontaneous emission.
But then there are
collisions which
just create a phase
hiccup, that the excited
state gets a random phase.
So an interruption of the
phase, an interruption
of the coherent
evolution is, in effect,
an interruption of us probing
the atoms in a coherent way.
And then the Fourier transform
just tells us, this time, or 1
over this time, is the
line which we observe.
And you would say,
but how does it
come into play with atoms
with a velocity distribution?
In the following way.
If you line up several atoms
and they interact with a laser
beam, some atoms are faster,
some atoms are slower.
If some of the atoms have
moved compared to the slower
atoms, one additional
wavelength,
then your ensemble
of atoms is no longer
interacting with the laser
beam in a phase-coherent way.
Because of the
different velocities,
they are now talking to
random phases of the laser.
So therefore,
Doppler broadening is
nothing else as a
loss of the atoms
to coherently interact with
a laser, because some of them
have moved an additional
wavelength in the laser beam.
Well, if that is true-- but what
happens if the laser beam is
like this, with the wavelengths,
and the atoms go perpendicular?
What happens then?
STUDENT: There's no Doppler.
PROFESSOR: Then there
is no Doppler effect.
So what I'm saying
is fully consistent
with every single thing you
know about the Doppler effect.
OK.
So I think there's not
much more we can do today.
But let me give you the
summary of this discussion.
To the best of my knowledge,
all line broadening mechanisms
can be described by using the
concept of coherence time.
And it's a coherence time
of a correlation function.
It's pretty much the
correlation function
of the phase which
the atom experiences.
At t equals 0, it experiences
one phase of your drive field.
And a later time, how
long does it stay coherent
with the coherent evolution
of the phase of your drive
field of a correlation function?
However, in the case
of inhomogeneous
broadening-- and
this is what I just
discussed with the
different atoms
starting together and
having different velocities.
In the case of
inhomogeneous broadening,
I have to include in the
description of the correlation
function ensemble averaging.
So this is our agenda.
On Wednesday, I will
start to discuss with you
very simple cases.
I sort of like, before I
introduce correlation function,
we have the
generalized discussion
to summarize for you the
phenomenological description
of just Rabi resonance, Ramsey
resonance, exponential decay,
simple Doppler broadening,
the recoil effect,
that you have a clear
physical picture of what
the different phenomena are.
And then we describe them
with a common language,
with a common
formalism, which is
a formalism of
correlation functions.
Any questions?
One obvious
question-- the chapter
on line shifts and broadening
will not be on the mid-term.
OK.
See you on Wednesday.